i therefore it is you pop culture fem
yes en science fiction fan
here all of a sudden science curiosity chelsea yes
yes yes
ipad and tablet with chakra here tak en
fame and room and reach for the sex is
still not quite sure
clear water works for nature nam
[Laughter  ]
universal process the refrigerator like
fields by my side
the french like it's not load and eating
and my
zo knows so exactly is waiting religions
with a taking time amrinder gill being
there as man of sorrows balloon vvd
Konings is comic book smoothie's tv and
since mar  basis like that work so my
imitate and spurs scenario of my best
my life the early life in cartoon and
comic symbolic tywin of tyson scifi
and zo age word jardin dorado do not the
world and far away but i just words
right now be purchased in oost  en
culture is no longer pop culture is the
culture and decrease of grace tanamal
burst in the zen liters of beer 1000 fresh
mind you would sometimes a moment en
gimme that it's like suck it literally
sp f  fx fourth thing is a job
incidence that's gonna be wrong time i
love my bones super ely and sorry man hef
my course pen mostly celebrating sphinx
dry and joy
largely moore's law the center the
iphone 6 with my dull and spotify
you may the brilliant red  sea life you peopl
thatcher itself community is the you w
re present me and i
rail 2 procession the wheel such an instr
ment and iphone the review i by phone
your fanbase there is right interest in a
n an
high five widow touch santing wheel
we oh my  god gimme gimme that
you can
[Music]